Hello, everyone, and welcome
to lecture 2 of CME 296.
So today is a very
exciting day because we'll
be talking about a new
generation paradigm, which
is going to be score matching.
So if you remember last week, we
saw a first generation paradigm
which was diffusion with DDPM.
So today we're going to
see a new way of doing this
and see how this relates
to the way we were doing
this with diffusion with DDPM.
So before we start,
I'm just going
to recap what we saw last week.
So if you remember, the
first three lectures
are all about understanding
how we can generate new samples
by trying to generate
from a distribution pdata
that we do not know that
is potentially complicated.
So here we have
nothing as input.
So it's unconditioned
generation.
And our goal is to learn a
way to generate new images.
So what did we see last time?
So our strategy
was to take images
from the training set that
we called clean because they
did not have any kind of noise.
And what we did is we
defined a process q that
added some noise progressively,
such that at the end of the day,
we ended up with just pure
noise or almost pure noise.
And the goal of DDPM was to
learn a reverse process that
was able to predict the noise
to remove from the noisy image.
So that was the strategy.
You take an image.
You gradually add some noise.
And what you do is you try to
learn how given a noisy image
and given the noise
level, how you can remove
the noise from that image.
So the way we went
about doing this
was through
likelihood estimation.
So we had our model p theta
that we're trying to learn.
And what we were doing
is trying to maximize
the probability of our model
seeing the data from a training
set.
But we saw that it
was intractable.
So what we did is we derived
a tractable lower bound
that we could also
maximize that could be
a good proxy for our objective.
And we ended up with
this ELBO formulation.
And what we did is we expanded
the terms from the lower bound.
And what we saw was that
there was some nice terms that
came out of it.
So there was, for
instance, a KL divergence
between exactly what
we wanted to learn
and the forward process that
we defined that was something
that we could express.
And then the third
step was to indeed show
that this was tractable.
And we leveraged the fact
that we were actually
defining our forward
process with Gaussian noise
and with Gaussian distributions.
And the good thing with
Gaussian distributions
is there's a lot of nice
properties, which is things
that we leverage here.
And at the end of the day,
we deduced a loss function
that was actually very simple.
It was a simple L2
regression loss on the noise
that we wanted to remove.
All good so far?
So this was last time.
And so this was the
loss that we had.
So we had the the noised image
as an input along with the noise
level.
And we had our model that we
wanted to train which is here,
the noise predictor--
epsilon theta.
And what we wanted
to do is to have
that match as close as possible
the actual noise that we use.
And as I mentioned, this way of
doing things was just one way.
And what we're
going to see today
is another way of doing this,
which is called score matching.
So I'm going to start
with just taking
another perspective of the
problem that we have at stake.
So remember that we
have some training
sets that contains some images.
So these are for instance, the
Teddy bear images that we have.
And our goal is to sample a new
image from that distribution.
So this set of images, they
come from a complex data
distribution, let's say,
pdata that we do not.
And our goal is
to sample from it.
Now, a very common strategy
that we will again reuse here
is to sample from
an easy distribution
and then to recover
the image that we
want to sample towards the end.
So here this cross this
represents maybe an observation
that we can sample that
is not part of pdata
but part of a distribution
that is easy to sample from.
So let's say Gaussian noise.
So given that what
we're wondering is,
is there a way to
go from something
that is easy to sample
towards something that
is hard to sample?
Does that make sense?
It's going to be
a bit more clear.
So let's imagine you have p
of x, which is the probability
density function that takes in
x, the representation of images
as input, and that tells
you the probability density
of it happening at x.
So this is what the
figure is showing.
So here darker colors mean
higher values of p of x.
So if you were over
here, what would
be a way for you to
come closer to regions
higher values of p of x?
So the answer is, let's
take the gradient.
So just as a reminder,
the gradient of a scalar
function here that
takes in as inputs
x, which is multidimensional,
and returns a scalar,
so the gradient of the function
is the vector of components,
partial derivative of
that function with respect
to each dimension of the
multidimensional space.
And what the gradient
here represents
is the direction where this
p of x is higher value.
So here the idea is
if we can have access
to gradient of p of x,
then from this starting
point, we can maybe go towards
regions higher density.
But there is a problem.
The problem is that estimating
the gradient of the probability
density function is actually
a very hard thing to do.
And there are a few
reasons for that.
So the first one is that
probability density functions,
by definition, they
are normalized,
meaning that if you
take the integral
towards the whole space,
the integral of p of x
needs to be equal to 1.
So you have this
constant, that maybe we
can note here z,
that is something
that is very hard, intractable
for you to compute,
because you would need to sum
across all possible values
of your space.
And space is
multi-dimensional, and it's
a lot of computation,
not something
that you can actually do.
So this quantity is intractable.
So if p of x is intractable,
then if you take the gradient,
it's also intractable.
So that's the first reason.
The second reason is different
compared to the first one, which
is due to the fact that the
probability density function can
take very low values in
certain regions of space
where there are very few data.
So let's suppose here--
let's say you have a point
here, then the probability
would be very small.
And so this can cause some
numerical stability issues.
So because of these
reasons, maybe we
can take a look at another
candidate of a way for you
to go from a certain
point towards regions
of high density of the space.
And that potential candidate
can be the gradient
of the log of the probability,
as opposed to just the gradient
of the probability.
So why could that be-- why
would that be a good candidate?
Well, do you remember
the first point
I mentioned regarding
the normalizing constant?
Well, thanks to the properties
of the logarithm function,
if you take the logarithm of the
numerator over the denominator,
it's just the logarithm of the
numerator minus the logarithm
of the denominator.
And given that the
normalizing constant
is constant with respect
to x, the point in space,
the gradient of log
of z is actually 0.
So what that means is in order
to compute the gradient of log
of p, you don't
have to figure out
how you want to compute
that intractable quantity.
So that's reason number 1.
Reason number 2, I'm not sure
if this was obvious to you,
but just to emphasize
on this a bit more,
the gradient of
the log is actually
pointing in the same direction
as the gradient of p.
And the reason for that
is just a calculus reason.
So the gradient of log of
p is equal to the gradient
of p over p.
And so what that means is
up to some normalization,
the gradient of the
log of p is pointing
towards the same direction
of gradient of p.
Because p is a scalar.
Just remember p is a scalar.
So it's as if you were dividing
your vector by the same quantity
across all dimensions.
First reason, it is tractable.
Second reason, it is pointing
in the same direction
as gradient of p.
And then the third reason is
that it is just more numerically
stable.
And the reason for that
is when gradient of p
is very, very small,
then there are chances
that p is also very small.
And so if you take the
ratio, it is not as small.
So that's the third reason.
So for all of these reasons,
a possible strategy for you
to go from one point
in space towards region
higher densities with respect to
the probability density function
can be to follow the direction
given by gradient of log
of p, which we call the score.
So this is the reason
why this lecture
is called score matching.
It is because we're interested
in this quantity, which
is the score, which is the
gradient of the log of p.
One note that I will add is
just see that I said gradient
of log of p with respect to x.
So you may think
it is redundant,
but it is actually because
we want to distinguish it
from another score,
which is with respect
to the parameters of a model
that sometimes people use.
And so I just want
to clarify here
that we take the
gradient with respect
to x, which is the
position in the space.
Sounds good?
OK.
Cool.
So this is how our score
would look like in space.
So here if you're further
away, typically the score,
the magnitude would
be bigger because you
have the gradient of p over p.
And p is small, and it's
smaller when you get closer
to the distribution.
So now a question that
I have for you is,
let's suppose we sample
from this space, sample
from a distribution that is easy
to sample, which is somewhere
in space.
And if I were to tell
you, if I were to ask you,
how would you go from this
point to higher density regions
of the space using the score?
How would you do it?
[AUDIO OUT]
Follow the score.
Yeah.
So you could follow the score.
So the reason why I'm
asking you this question
is because there is a catch.
Because if you
follow the score, it
means that you're going
towards higher density
regions of the space.
But the problem is
you may always go
where the density is highest.
And so here when you look
at this illustration,
there are places where
density is not the highest,
but it is still a valid
sample from the distribution.
So actually what
we want is not only
go towards higher density
places of the region,
but also to have some
diversity, to not always go
at the same place.
So that's the reason why.
Let's assume we know the score.
We would use a sampling method
that is very commonly used,
and I'm going to call out now,
which is called the Langevin
sampling.
And what that does
is it not only allows
you to go towards higher
density regions of the space,
but also have a
stochastic term that
allows you to go to explore
a little bit the region.
So I displayed the formula
here on the slide a little bit
out of nowhere.
So we won't have
time to derive it.
But I just want to
show you that there
is a way for you to start
from a starting point,
and then use the score
to end up with a sample
from the probability
distribution.
And that method is
called Langevin sampling.
So if you know
about MCMC methods,
so Markov Chain Monte
Carlo, so Langevin sampling
is just one such methods.
That sounds good?
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yep.
Yeah, so the question is,
are these coefficients
coming out of nowhere?
Are they're here for a reason?
The answer is yes.
They're here for a reason.
And they can be derived
using some equations.
So if you've heard
Fokker-Planck equation
is something that you
can use to derive this.
We won't have time to derive
it, but there is a reason.
There is a reason for this.
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yes.
So the question is, is
there a convergence concern
because the score
is getting lower
and you always go
from one to the other?
Is that the question?
So we will see that
later on and see how
that is actually not a concern.
But yeah, great question.
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is, how
do you choose alpha?
And we're going to
also see that later.
But it is something
that you choose.
Cool.
Great questions.
And with that, I for
now assume that we
knew how to get the score.
But the reality is we don't.
So we're going to spend
this first part just trying
to see how we can
estimate the score.
And it is actually
not an easy problem,
and we're going to see why.
So first of all, the task
of estimating the score
is widely known
as score matching,
because you're trying
to match the score.
So here the way you want to do
it is similar with the noise L2
regression.
You also want to have
some L2 regression,
but this time on the score.
But the main problem is you
don't know what pdata is,
and you also do not know the
score of the data distribution.
So looking at this
loss function,
there's actually no way for
you to estimate s theta of x.
So that's the reason
why there's been
a few papers across the
years, along the years, that
have tried to estimate this
score function without having
the need to know the
true score function.
So I'm just going to enumerate a
few methods that were out there.
For instance, this
one is back in 2005,
there was a method called
Implicit Score Matching that
derived a loss that
actually did not
require you to have the
knowledge of the true score
function.
And there is another method
called Sliced Score Matching,
which used the
fact of projecting
the score on different random
vectors, random projections.
So I put the papers at
the bottom of the slide.
We're not going to
go into details just
because these methods
are not really
commonly used like nowadays.
But instead what
we're going to do
is to focus on the common
method that is being used,
which is called
denoising score matching.
And it relies on the
following observation.
So I told you that
we do not have
the knowledge of the score
of the true distribution,
because the true distribution
is a complex distribution.
But I also told you that
Gaussian distributions
have very nice properties.
So one idea that we
can have is let's
try to see if we can compute
the score of a Gaussian
distribution.
So let's assume that we
have a random variable
x that is drawn from a normal
distribution of mean mu
and variance sigma squared.
So here I'm taking an example
in 1D just so that we're--
so that it's easier.
So the probability distribution
function or probability density
function is given
by this formula,
which is analytically explicit.
It is something
that is given here.
Well, it turns out
that if you take
the gradient of
the log of p, then
you end up with this very
nice formulation of minus x
minus mu over sigma squared.
Should we derive it, or is
it, quote unquote, "obvious"?
You want to derive it?
No?
OK.
Maybe one thing I will
do is to just tell you
why this formula makes sense.
So if you consider a
Gaussian distribution,
the probability density function
would be something like this.
You'll have high densities
towards the mean.
And then you will have lower
values of the densities
as you go away.
So here what you're
saying is if you
take some x in space,
what it is saying
is the score at that point
x is given by minus x
minus mu over sigma squared.
So what that means is, so
minus x minus mu is mu minus x.
Oops.
So it's supposed to
be a straight line.
So let's suppose
it's a straight line.
It's going to be
somewhere like this.
Sigma squared is positive.
So it's going to be
pointing towards the mean.
And just remember
that the score is
a quantity that gives us the
direction of higher densities
in the space.
So just to tell you that
this formula makes sense.
So back to our original goal.
So what we want is to
find a way to compute
the score of a distribution.
And we saw that computing the
score of a Gaussian distribution
is easy.
So how about we take one
point from our training
set and we noise it.
So let's suppose we're given
x from our training set.
And let's suppose we
add some Gaussian noise,
and we scale it with sigma.
Then we have x tilde, which is
equal to x plus sigma epsilon.
So x tilde follows a
normal distribution
of mean x and variance
sigma squared I.
And using exactly these results,
you get that the score of--
so we're calling that q
sigma of x tilde given x.
So this quantity is actually
something that is tractable.
So now the question is,
how can we use that result
in order to go back to our
initial objective, which
is to determine the score of the
data distribution of interest?
So just remember at the
first starting point
we want to estimate the score
of pdata, which is like this.
Well, the key idea here is to
take that data distribution
and to noise it.
So for that, we're
going to introduce
q sigma of x tilde,
which is this quantity.
And I'm going to explain
what that quantity is.
So what I'm going to do is to
just rewrite the expression
on the blackboard.
And maybe it's here.
[AUDIO OUT]
OK.
Thank you.
So you have q sigma of x tilde.
Whoops.
So it is a function
of this perturbation.
So it's called the
perturbation kernel.
So you take one data point
from your data distribution.
And then you noise it.
So this is the one.
And what you're
actually doing is
you're repeating that
procedure for all elements
of your training set.
Which is why you're ending
up with this distribution.
So this is an
expression that takes
in each point of
your training set.
And that noises it.
And you just repeat that process
for all points of your training
set.
And this you can interpret it as
a joint probability distribution
that you can also note q
sigma of x tilde and x,
which is a valid one.
Because if you integrate over
x tilde and x, you get one.
So I just want you to
look at this formula
and just not be scared
about what that means.
I think it's quite easy.
Another way of seeing
this is in practice,
what you have is only a few data
points from your distribution.
So it's as if you were saying
you take the finite set of data
points that you have from your
distribution, and what you do
is you noise each of it.
So it's as if you were obtaining
a mixture of Gaussians.
It's as if you were obtaining--
you have your different points.
And what you do is you
noise, you noise each point.
And so we're going
to call q sigma of x
tilde the noisy distribution.
Yeah?
Cool.
So as you can tell, q sigma
is a function of sigma.
And sigma tells you
how much noise you're
adding to the distribution.
So if you have, let's say, a
small sigma, your distribution
is just a little bit noisy.
So it just spreads a little bit.
But then as you add
more and more noise,
it just spreads out and
takes much more space.
So how can you use these
definitions in order
for us to compute
the true score?
So we're going to see it now.
So let's consider the
score matching objective
not on the original
data distribution
but on the noisy distribution.
So if we take q
sigma of x tilde,
we have the squared
distance between the score
of x tilde and the--
sorry, the predicted score
and the true score of x tilde.
Well, there is a paper that
showed that this is actually
equivalent to optimizing for
another loss function, which
is this one, which is s theta
of x tilde minus the score,
but conditioned on each data
points of your training set.
And so why is this good news?
It is because that
conditional score is something
that we already saw.
It is tractable, but
we have a problem.
And the problem we're
going to see later.
Before we do that,
I'm just trying
to see if we have
time to derive it.
So the derivation is in between
being trivial and not trivial.
It's in the middle.
I would say the
proof is quite nice.
It is not required for
you to know for the exam.
So I think in the
interest of time,
I'm not going to
do the full proof,
but I'm going to show you
how you can derive it just
through the main step.
So what we're saying is we have
the original score matching
function, which is the
one at the top, which
is the squared distance
between the score of the noise
observation minus the
true score of q sigma.
What we're saying is optimizing
for these loss function
is the same as
optimizing for this one.
So the expectation is over
x over your training set
and then x tilde,
which is given x.
And so it's
expectation of, again,
the score of the
noisy observation,
but this one minus
the true score
of the conditional
observation condition on x.
So what you want to
show this is the same
as optimizing for this,
which is tractable.
So the trick here is
to recognize the fact
that you have a distance of
two quantities, let's say, a
and b, which is something that
you can expand as follows.
So the distance
between a and b squared
is a squared minus 2
dot product of a and b
plus this square norm of b.
And what you see is--
so these two loss
functions, you want
to optimize them with
respect to the parameters
of the model, which is theta.
And so you first realize
that the b term in both loss
functions, they are not
a function of theta.
So actually you don't care.
So this one you ignore.
And then you look at just
the first term, the a term.
And you just realize that
these terms are the same.
So this one you also don't care.
The only thing that
you care is showing
that the expectation
across x tilde of the dot
product between the two is
the same as the expectation
of over x and x tilde of the dot
product between these prediction
model and this
conditional score.
You want to show that
these two are equal.
And this is what the
proof is showing.
So if you're interested
in the details,
I would highly encourage
you to take a look
at the original paper, which
is the denoising score matching
paper in the appendix.
So it's maybe a five
or six-line derivation.
And what it does is
it just leverages
the definition of q
sigma and then just does
some nice term expansion
and term identification.
So all I want to say is
that this equivalence is not
pure magic.
It's just math, math.
And what is great
about it is that we're
able to optimize the loss
of the score matching
for the noisy distribution
using a tractable loss.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is, the
score of the noisy data
is equal to the score
of the conditional.
Well, not exactly, but what your
model s theta of x tilde learns
ends up being the same.
And the reason for that is
because here what you care about
is the direction where
you're optimizing your model.
So you do gradient
descent typically.
And what you care
about is the gradient
of that loss with
respect to theta.
And so that's why we have
this whole derivation
to just show that the
loss at the bottom
is equal to the one at the top,
plus some constant that is not
a function of theta.
And for that reason,
if you optimize
the loss that is
tractable from the bottom,
it's the same as optimizing
the loss from the top.
[AUDIO OUT]
They're not equal.
Yes, exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
Great question.
Any other questions on this?
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Great question.
So the question is,
what is the intuition
behind this being the same?
So I think the
intuition goes back
to the way you define
q sigma and the way
taking the expectation works.
So here what you're saying is
if you take a look at scores
conditioned on points
from the training sets,
so if you take a look at
this, and then if you somehow
see all the different scores
from all the different points
conditioned on these
points, then on average
is going to be
the same as if you
were to actually take the
score from the overall noisy
distribution.
That's the rough intuition.
Does that make sense?
OK.
OK, cool.
I'm looking at the time.
So let's see.
Yeah, so again, the
proof is not something
that we will expect in the exam.
So feel free to just take a look
at it if you're just curious.
But it's not required.
So this is also called L of DSM,
so Denoising Score Matching.
And again this loss is
tractable because you
know the score of q sigma
of x tilde conditional
on x, because this is
a score of a Gaussian.
So just recapping where we
are, what we wanted to do
is to estimate the score
of the true distribution.
So what we said was,
OK, it's actually
not something we can do.
Let's fall back on
an easier setup.
And what we said was that
the easier setup was that
in the Gaussian case, you are
able to analytically compute
the true score.
So what we did is we took
the true data distribution,
and we noised it.
And what we showed
was that optimizing
for the loss that
is not tractable
is the same as optimizing
for loss that is tractable.
So in other words, you are
able to estimate the score
of a noisy data distribution.
But it is still not equal to
pdata, because what you want
is pdata.
You don't want the
noisy data distribution.
So it's only something
that is going
in the direction
of what we want,
but it's not exactly
what we want.
So let's see what this
q sigma looks like.
So what we want, again, is
to go from a starting point
towards the data distribution.
But here we do not have
the score of the true data
distribution.
So how about if we take
a noisy distribution
that we can compute where
sigma is very, very small.
So when sigma is
very, very small,
q sigma is very close
to pdata distribution,
because we noise it
just a little bit.
Well, the problem is that if
we take q sigma with sigma
that is very small,
then we'll just
have poor estimations of the
score in low-density regions.
Do you see why?
So I'm probably going
to just explain this.
So the good thing is
it's already there.
So I'm just going to fall back
on the definition of the loss
here.
So this is the loss
that we're optimizing.
So what that means
is that we want
to optimize on the loss
that is around the distance
between the predicted
score and the score
of the noisy distribution
q, which is equal to this.
So you're weighting your
loss function with respect
to how likely your points
x tilde are to appear.
So in other words, if x tilde
is not likely to appear,
then the fact that it is
off from the true value
is not something that is
going to be materially
noticeable in the loss.
So the model will not
really be incentivized
to make predictions
accurate for x tilde
that are not likely to appear.
OK.
So does this part make sense?
So what I'm saying
here is we are
able to estimate the score of
this noisy data distribution,
but we're not able to
estimate it accurately
in places of the
space that are not
likely to appear under q sigma.
That's what I'm saying.
And the problem
with that is if you
sample from a
distribution that is
easy to sample from, for
instance, a Gaussian,
well, most of the time you're
in regions that are low density.
So if you use the score
of a noisy distribution
with a small noise,
then you will not
have estimations
of that score that
will be accurate in those
low density regions.
So you will not be
to accurately go
towards the
high-density regions.
So in other words,
I'm going just
to explain this a bit more
on an illustration here.
So it's as if we were saying
that we have our complicated
data distribution here that we
have maybe noise a little bit.
So it's like this.
So this one is pdata,
and this one is q sigma.
So what I'm saying
here is we are
able to compute the
score of this q sigma,
but we're not able
to estimate it
accurately in spaces of low
density, so for instance, here.
So what that means is if
I sample an observation
from an easy distribution that
is in a low-density region,
then when I'm going
to use the score
to get closer to that
region, those estimates
they may be super off.
So I won't be able to
come towards where I want.
And that is the problem with
a small amount of noise.
So what do you do, well, you can
tell me just increase the noise,
then.
Because if you
increase the noise,
then if you add
enough noise, like,
let's suppose q sigma with sigma
big, then that point in space
will be covered with
a high enough density
such that you can have
more accurate estimations
of the score of the
noisy distribution.
But the problem is
that now q sigma is
too different from your p data.
So in other terms,
what you're learning
is not exactly what you want.
It's like something
that's different.
So you have this trade-off.
If you have too little
noise, then it's good.
What you're trying to learn is
very close to what you actually
want to learn, which a the score
of the true data distribution.
But the problem is you do
not have good estimates
in low-density regions.
But at the same time, if you
have too high of a noise,
well, the distribution now is
too different from the true data
distribution.
But you now can have
good estimations.
So it's a little bit
like the bias variance
trade-off in a sense.
You just don't have
both at the same time
in this case, which is making
the situation complicated.
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is, if we
configure the Langevin sampling
in a way that can work,
then we can make this work?
So the answer is yes.
So it's the next part.
And we're going to see
how we can do that.
But yeah, that's
a good intuition.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is, why is
it poor of an estimation
in low-density scores?
This is true.
It's correct, this one.
Not this one actually, the
tractable one is the true one.
But the only problem is that
the tractability of your loss
function is also a function
of how you configured it
in terms of the expectation.
So the expectation
here is over q sigma,
meaning that if you have an x
tilde, which is in low-density
regions, then it's just not
going to have a high weight
loss, which is just not
incentivizing your model
to actually properly learn it.
So in a sense, it's a
loss-weighting problem.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the predicted score
will be inaccurate.
Yes.
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is, how about
the regularity conditions
of the function?
So here let's assume that
this is not a problem.
Here let's assume
it's not a problem.
But you're right that, for
instance, for sigma very small
you have indeed very spiky ones.
This is the correct intuition.
So yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yes, exactly.
So high noise smoothens it.
Low noise produces
some spikiness
around those
training data points.
OK, cool.
I think this is probably
the most challenging part
of the lecture.
So yeah, hope you
got the intuition
as to why that is a problem.
So what are we going to do?
And you had the right
intuition in terms
of making some tweaks to
the Langevin sampling.
So what we're going
to do is now we're not
going to learn the score
of one distribution.
We're going to learn the
score of several distributions
of several noise levels.
So instead of
predicting s theta of x,
we're going to predict s theta
of x where you're in space
and sigma your noise level.
And the idea here is to consider
several distributions, one
with a small amount of noise,
then bigger, then bigger, then
bigger.
And the way you're going to use
those different score estimates
is at the very beginning--
so if I show you my
beautiful charts here.
At the very beginning,
what you care
about is knowing
roughly where to go,
where to go in space, roughly.
So here it's fine if you have
the score of a distribution that
is quite approximate from
the true one, as long
as you know roughly
where you need to go.
So the idea is
here, you will use
the score of a distribution
that has been very noisy.
And let's say you're going
to go somewhere here.
And then at that
point, you're going
to use the score
of a distribution
with less noise, because maybe
that distribution with less
noise covers that region.
And now you know maybe
a little bit better
where the actual high-density
regions of the true data
distribution is.
And you're going to go again
with lower amount of noise
again and again and
again until coming here.
So that is the idea.
You're not going to only rely on
one kind of noisy distribution
with a small amount
of noise or one
with a higher amount of noise.
You're going to actually
rely on all of them
in a way that will make
this problem easy for you.
So at the very beginning,
what you care about
is roughly where to go.
And then the more
you get closer,
you care more and more
about the little details.
And these methods is
something that you
will recognize with the
following name, so NCSN, Noise
Conditional Score Network.
So is this framework of learning
scores of different noise
levels.
So I just want to reiterate
what I drew on the blackboard.
So let's suppose you sample an
observation from a distribution
that is easy to sample from that
is far from your actual data
distribution.
So what you do is
you will actually
rely on the predicted score from
a noised data distribution that
is very noisy.
And you're going
to go step by step
by relying on scores
from distribution that
are less and less noise until
coming to your last point, which
is something that hopefully will
be very, very close to the pdata
distribution, which is
going to be a noise data
distribution with
a very low sigma.
OK.
So does that make sense?
Yeah?
OK.
Cool
So back to your intuition
on the Langevin sampling.
So your intuition
was 100% correct.
This way of sampling things that
I explained with varying noise
levels is actually called
annealed Langevin dynamics.
And it's this idea of starting
with a high amount of noise
and decreasing the
noise progressively.
So you will also see that
in the literature as ALD.
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is, what is
exactly the trade-off here?
So the idea is with a
high amount of noise,
if you add a high
enough amount of noise,
then previous low-density
regions will be covered
by the noisy distribution.
And if you add
enough noise, like,
with a very high amount of
sigma, then you will cover it.
The only problem is--
so you can learn the score of
that very noisy distribution.
But the problem is that the true
score of that noisy distribution
is going to be far from the
score of the data distribution.
So that is the trade-off.
[AUDIO OUT]
Right.
So the direction that
it will be pointing
will be roughly where you
want to go, but not exactly.
But the idea here is that
the very beginning you
don't really care.
So for instance, if
from here from Stanford,
I want to go to New York, I know
roughly I want to go this way.
And then I go this way.
And then the more I
get closer, the more
I want to refine exactly
where New York is.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
There is something
else I wanted to say.
OK.
So there's something
else I wanted to say,
which I think we'll
cover a little bit later.
But first, we're
going to cover how
we're going to sample
new observations
using this annealed
Langevin dynamics.
So here what you
would do is sample
some noise from
very noisy Gaussian
with a high amount of noise.
And what you're going to do
is for every noise level,
you're going to run
your Langevin sampling.
And this is the formula that we
saw at the very beginning, which
is you add the point that you're
at with the predicted score,
which is where you
want to go, and then
some amount of noise, which
allows for a bit of diversity.
And once you do that
for all noise levels
until coming to a very
small noise level,
then you end up with
the actual image.
So one thing that I want
to say regarding the score,
you can think of the
score as being a compass.
Now, when you are in
the forest and you
want to see where
the city is, just
follow the direction
of the compass.
It's the same idea here.
So we're in the space,
space of images.
A lot of these regions
of space are images that
are actually not real images.
But what you want is
to go towards regions
of high density with respect to
your target data distribution.
So it's as if you were
following a compass
to come at your destination.
OK, cool.
So last time-- you
had a question?
[AUDIO OUT]
Oh, yeah.
So the question is
data distribution
can be any data distribution?
Yes, yes.
OK.
So now what I want to tell you
is how what I'm telling you
now here relates to
what we saw last week.
So if you remember, DDPM was
all about taking a clean image
and then noising it.
So if you remember, we
had these coefficients.
And for instance, in this
case, the noised image
was the square root of alpha
t bar times your clean image
plus square root of 1 minus
alpha t bar times the noise.
What I told you here
also involves noise.
So a natural question
that you may ask is,
how does the score relate
to the noise prediction task
that we saw last week?
Well, the forward
process of xt given x0,
you just see that it is a
normal distribution centered
on the square root of
alpha t bar times x0.
And you actually realize that
the score of that distribution
is equal to minus the noise that
you added over some coefficient.
So in other words,
these two quantities,
so the score meaning
where you should
go to end up where
the clean images are
and the noise that you
added, are actually
two quantities that are linked.
And they are linked
such that the score
is equal to minus the
noise that you added.
And that makes sense.
So why does that make sense?
So I'm just going
to clean that part.
Whoops.
So why does that make sense?
So here if you have
your clean image
and then if you noised,
so it's as if you added
some amount of something noise.
But then if you want to go
back to high-density regions
it's basically your score.
So it makes sense that the two
are in opposite directions.
So by the way, does that make
sense that it is the formula?
So maybe I can also derive it.
So remember that the score
of a normal distribution
is equal to minus x minus
the mean over the variance.
So in this case, we have--
so x, what is x?
It's a noisy image.
And the noisy image has
the following formula.
So noisy image is
the square root
of alpha t bar times
x0 plus square root
of 1 minus alpha t
bar times epsilon.
You subtract the mean of
the normal distribution,
which is this square root
of alpha t bar times x0.
So this gives you minus.
And then this is square root
of 1 minus alpha t bar epsilon
over your variance, which
is 1 minus alpha t bar.
Which is exactly what
you have on the slides.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Cool.
So this is just to give you a
parallel between NCSN and DDPM.
So these two methods are
just two different ways
of noising your sample at the
end of the day, because one
is taking some weighted average
between the clean sample
x0 and the noise, and the
other one is just adding noise
with just sigma.
So that is the reason
why this, so DDPM, you
will see it be characterized
as being variance preserving.
Because if you take
the variance of xt
is going to be
roughly equal to 1.
And this is assuming that
your x0 are normalized.
They have a mean of
0 and variance of 1.
So if you take the
variance of xt,
it's roughly alpha t bar plus--
so square root of alpha t bar
squared plus square root of
1 minus alpha t bar squared,
which is equal to 1 roughly.
And this formulation,
the NCSN one
is going to be mentioned as
being variants exploding.
Oh, I have to go way
back in the slides.
This one is going to be variance
exploding because you're going
to add more and more noise.
And the noise is going
to just increase a lot.
So it's not bounded by 1.
OK.
Cool.
So, so far what
we've seen is noising
images using a discrete
set of noise increments.
But one could argue that these
discretization is arbitrary.
It is something that you need
to decide before starting
your training process.
So one idea is to actually
consider continuous evolution
instead of discrete one.
So the reason why you would
be interested in doing that
is because we also
have a field of math,
which is in differential
equations that
have a bunch of very
convenient toolkits to solve
these kinds of equations.
So one idea is to
actually start from what
we saw in DDPM and NCSN and
try to see how they would be
like in the continuous world.
So in order to do
that, we first need
to have an equivalent
of noise increments.
Because up until now, the way
we added noise to clean images
was via sampling from a
Gaussian distribution.
So it's like normal
distribution of mean 0
and covariance
matrix, the identity,
and then just adding
noise like this.
But what you want is to have a
continuous equivalent of having
these noise increments.
And this is where the
Wiener process comes in.
So who has heard of the
Wiener process before?
Yeah.
No one?
Maybe one.
OK.
So the Wiener process is a
type of stochastic process.
So stochastic process is a
family of random variables
that are indexed by some
index t, let's say, the time.
And a Wiener process
is a stochastic process
that follows the
following properties.
So we have W0 by definition
that is equal to 0.
And the difference between Wt
and Ws, which is an increment,
follows a normal
distribution of mean 0
and variance t minus s times
I. And these increments,
so these differences
are actually
independent from one another.
So you can think of the
equivalent of a random walk.
So you walk one
here and then one
there but in the
continuous world.
So one thing that I want to
say is that what is independent
is the increments and not the
value of the ability itself.
Because you can imagine that
Wt will depend on Wt minus 1
and so on.
So what we're saying is
that the increments are
independent from one another.
So with that in
mind, what we can do
is to derive a continuous
formulation of DDPM and NCSN.
So in the interest of
time, what I'm going to do
is to only derive the DDPM case.
So what we're saying
is we're starting
from the update
formula that adds noise
to a less noisy image.
And what we want is to
obtain a continuous way
of expressing that.
So I'm just going to rewrite
what is on the slide.
So xt is equal to square root
of 1 minus beta of xt minus 1
plus square root of
beta times epsilon.
So if you remember, beta
is your noise schedule.
It's the amount of noise that
you add at each time step.
And so what you want is to have
an expression of a differential
evolution in x as a
function of everything else.
So what I'm going to do
is subtract that quantity
with xt minus 1 And then
have t and t minus 1
be very, very
small so that I can
consider this to be continuous.
So what I'm going to do
here is just some math.
So I'm taking xt and I'm
subtracting xt minus 1.
So it's going to be square
root of 1 minus beta minus 1,
xt minus 1 plus square
root of beta t epsilon.
So beta t is the
quantity of noise
that you add between
two discrete steps.
What I'm going to do
is to define a quantity
that I'm going to
write beta parenthesis
t, which is the rate of
noise at time t times
dt, an increment of time.
So what this is
saying is when we're
going to have t10 to 0-- so
this is going to 10 to 0,
but we're going to have
some rates of noise that's
going to be nonzero, that's
going to be your schedule.
So if I pause that, so this
becomes xt minus xt minus 1
is equal to, so 1 minus
beta t dt minus 1 xt minus 1
plus square root--
I'm going to also
replace it here--
of beta t dt epsilon.
So far I've just plugged in
the new beta t expression.
So what we're
going to obtain now
is actually something that's
going to be quite nice.
So if we tend t to 0, so if we
consider a continuous evolution,
xt minus xt minus
1 is also going
to be a differential evolution.
So here, I'm going to rewrite xt
minus xt minus 1 as just d of x.
So when dt tends to 0, you have
Taylor expansion formulas that
tells you that square root of 1
minus something that tends to 0,
which is equal to 1 minus
1/2 of that something.
So this is just
Taylor expansion.
So here, I'm going to say it's
roughly equal to 1 minus 1/2
of beta t dt.
xt minus 1 is roughly
going to be x.
So this is 1 minus this
minus 1, because you
have the 1 here, times x plus--
so you have square
root of beta t.
But then the Wiener
process that we defined
is such that a small increment
in the Wiener process
is actually something
that you can rewrite
as being square root
of dt times epsilon,
because it follows a normal
distribution of variance dt
times I.
So here, I'm going to recognize
the square root of dt times e.
That's right.
Square root of dt times epsilon
as being dW, which is equal--
so it's as if it was
equal to d of x is equal,
so this is going to cancel out,
1/2 of beta x dt plus square
root of B dW.
And now you may
be wondering, why
am I writing all
these equations?
Why are we doing this?
Well, you're going to see
that when we rewrite this,
for instance, for DDPM and
then for NCSN, what we realize
is that we have an expression
of dx equal to something times
dt plus something times dW.
So these two terms have
very specific names.
So one is called the drift.
So this quantity is
called the drift.
So it's deterministic.
And this one is
called the diffusion,
which is what is stochastic.
And you actually have a
nice intuition about it
when it comes to how
x varies in space.
So if you suppose x
to start from here
and you only have
a drift term, what
you're going to have is just
deterministic evolution using
f of x and t.
So you're going
to go from x to x
plus dx using f of xt times dt.
And then you're going to repeat
this process again and again
in a deterministic fashion.
So this first term
is deterministic.
Now let's look at what
the second term does.
So here you start
from a point x,
and you add some quantity
that is a function of noise,
Gaussian noise.
So here it's going to be
something that is noisy, so
the stochastic part.
Which means that if you
take the whole expression,
you're going to end
up with something--
so one step from
x to x plus dx is
going to be including
a deterministic step
and a stochastic step.
And this is something that
will follow the slides here.
So all I want to say is that
DDPM and NCSN can actually
be transcribed from their
discrete formulations
to a continuous one.
So when you see
these formulas, just
know that it is
just us transcribing
them to be continuous.
And the reason why
we want to do that
is because this is going
to be an SDE, so Stochastic
Differential Equation, for
which the field already
has a lot of techniques
to solve them.
And I'm just going
to tell you now
about why the DDPM
formula makes sense just
from an intuitive perspective.
So what we're saying is in a 2D
space, so this is the origin.
This is 0.
And then we have a vector x.
So what we're saying is
that an increment in x
is going to be negative
with respect to where x is.
So it's going to be
somewhere like this.
And then we're going to have
a little bit of noise added
to it, so maybe like this.
So in other words
the noising process,
the forward process is
bringing x closer to 0
and adding some
noise so that this
converges to a variance of 1,
which is what DDPM is about.
Because the DDPM you
take a clean image,
and then you noise it with
convenience coefficients
such that after t steps, it
becomes a normal distribution
of mean 0 and variance 1.
And this is exactly
what you're also
seeing by interpreting the
terms of this equation.
Does that make sense?
So I just want to tell
you this to just tell you
that these formulas
are not just formulas.
They have a meaning if
you think about each term.
And here this expression
of the continuous evolution
of the forward process for DDPM
actually makes intuitive sense
when you're just
writing things down.
[AUDIO OUT]
So question is,
why is it useful?
We're going to see
it exactly now.
So I'm going to tell
you now what is useful.
So the reason why
it's useful is 1,
you're not going to have
to necessarily define
discretization steps
between each noised images.
So you're not
going to say, OK, I
need let's say t steps to do
the whole noising process.
So that's the number 1.
And number 2 is there's
a number of results
in the field of stochastic
differential equations, which
is essentially what this is.
There's a number of
results that will allow you
to solve the reverse process.
Because what you want is to
be able to denoise images.
So here what we're doing is
we're just noising images.
But what we care about
is how to denoise images,
which is the reverse process.
And the reason why it
is convenient for us
to think in the
continuous world is
for us to be able to
leverage these results.
And we're going to see these
results in a few minutes.
OK, cool.
So here I just want to
say that this drift term
f and the diffusion g is
the following for DDPM,
but it is this form for NCSN.
And you see that there
is no drift term,
and it is mainly because
we're only adding noise.
And the idea behind
DDPM and score matching
is actually something that
was developed in parallel.
So here what I want to say is
just a historical evolution
of how things happened
and how we came up
to that unified view of
describing the forward process
in order to solve
the reverse process.
So on the one side, the
diffusion literature
had this given branch
with a 2015 paper
just describing how you can
derive a tractable loss in order
to solve for this,
the diffusion problem.
And then you have
the DDPM paper which
came out in 2020
that successfully
applied that for images.
That was on the one side.
And on the other side in
to score matching world,
you had this principle
of using the score
to go from a starting point to
the distribution and the fact
that it alleviated this
intractable normalizing
constant.
And then there was a
paper that described
how to do that in the case
of a noise distribution.
And then the NCSN
method is actually
something that came
out with a later paper.
And there is one
paper that unified
both of these paradigms, which
is a paper called Score-Based
Generative Modeling Through
Stochastic Differential
Equation, which is a paper
I highly recommend reading.
It's actually written
by folks from Stanford,
so Yang Song and coauthors.
And it is from that moment that
the community has seen these two
paradigms as being unified.
And this is the way we
have seen this play out.
So now why did we do
this in the first place?
So our goal is to
recover clean images.
So we know how to noise them
through this forward process
that we now are able to
express in continuous term.
What we care about is to
denoise into clean images.
And so here what we're doing
again predicting the score.
So this score
formulation is just
a regression on the
conditional score which
we saw was tractable,
which is, as we saw,
minus epsilon over
some coefficients.
And the way you would
train such a model
is following this
loss function, which
is an expectation over
clean images that you noise.
And so what you do is you
sample a clean image and then
some noise and time step.
And then what you do is you
obtain your noised image.
And so here noised image
is just a combination
of the clean image and the noise
with some alpha and sigma t,
which can be chosen either in
the DDPM way or another way.
And what you do is
you predict the score
that you know is tractable using
your noised image and your time
step.
But now you may be
asking, well, why do
you want to predict the score?
Because we saw that for
NCSN, we had the score
that we used in order to sample
new observations from the data
distribution.
But we saw in the case
of DDPM that we actually
predicted the noise to remove.
So we had these two
different formulations.
So now the question
that you may ask is,
why do you want to
focus on the score here?
And the answer to that is
that the forward process that
is described by the SDE can be
reversed through a reverse SDE
that involves the score.
So I'm just going to
repeat exactly what I said.
So the forward process, which
is described by the SDE,
is something that you can
reverse through a reverse SDE
which involves the score.
And the reason why the
score is popping up here
is due to some derivations that
we're not going to go here,
but this is just a result that
comes from a paper from 1982.
So it's a result
from the SDE world
that were just leveraging here.
So that is one of
the points why we're
caring about the
continuous formulation
is because we want to
be able to leverage
results around these SDEs,
and this is one of them.
And so now I want to
walk you through what
that reverse process
equation is about.
So I told you that the forward
process was composed of a drift
term and a diffusion term.
So it was dx equal
to f of x and t times
dt, which is the drift,
and then plus gt times
dW, which is the stochastic
term, the diffusion term.
And what we're saying is that in
order to do the reverse process,
we actually cannot just
have the same equation.
We need to add a correction
in the drift that
involves the score.
And here is the intuition.
The intuition is that
in the forward process,
we have added some stochasticity
that made us deviate from where
the actual data point was.
So as a result of
that, when we want
to reverse that process,
what we actually
want to counteract
this phenomenon
is to go towards the regions
of high density scaled
by that diffusion factor.
So what I'm telling you is
that the reverse process
SDE is obtained through
some derivation.
But the way you
would interpret it
is that the correction to
the drift is due to the fact
that you diffused in
the forward process.
And this made you be further
from high-density regions.
So this is what the
reverse process is like.
So it's dx times
the drift, which
is the original drift
minus the diffusion
coefficient times the score
times dt plus your diffusion
term.
And here we noted dW bar
because the Wiener process
from the reverse process
is actually different
compared to the one from the
forward process, which is
why we noted this with the bar.
And we're just going to conclude
with how you would do inference.
So to do inference, you
just sample some noise.
And then again what you do is
you leverage the nice results
from the fact that
you are handling SDEs,
Stochastic
Differential Equations.
So you, for instance, will use
a solver called Euler-Maruyama
that is able to numerically
solve the reverse process.
So here you can think of it
as a numerical method that
will let you go from your
original ex back to the endpoint
using the reverse
process equation.
And you will obtain your final
image, which will hopefully
be an image that is satisfying.
And that's going to
be your final image.
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yes, so this one-- yeah.
Yeah.
So here, you can
think of this equation
as being a discretization of
the reverse SDE which is here.
So this is exactly this SDE, but
you're doing it step by step.
[AUDIO OUT]
So the question is,
what is fx of t?
What is g?
So these are the
coefficients that are here.
So for instance, in this case, f
of x and t is minus 1/2 of beta
times x.
And g is square root of b.
[AUDIO OUT]
It is the same.
So the question is,
this is for the forward.
But this f and g are the same
in the forward and backwards.
Yep.
And with that, I'm going
to give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine.
So I'm going to come here
and sing a very similar song
as the one I sang last
week when we transitioned
from DDPM to DDIM.
So we're going to look at
this reverse SDE equation
and look at what is
not optimal in practice
and see what we can do about it.
So as Afshine mentioned, you
have this Brownian motion.
That is one term of that
reverse is the equation.
And what problem do
we have with that?
So as you saw in the transition
from x and x plus dx,
you have all these spikes that
happen due to the stochasticity.
And this process is the reason
why we cannot take large steps
when resolving it, because
otherwise you would be
approximating a movement that
is something that you look
at the microscopic level.
So you need a high
number of steps
in your solver to start with.
And also the second
point is that when
you look at your
errors that you do
when you solve these
reverse SDE equation,
you have now two sources.
You have the first
source that comes
from the regular
discretization step.
And then you have the
stochastic error that comes in,
and they accumulate.
So just like last
week, I'm going
to paint the picture of what
we would like to have and see
if we can get there.
So what would be the
right counterpart
of an SDE in a nicer world?
It would be an ODE.
So the ODE does have
this term on the left
but doesn't have
any stochasticity.
And going through each
point that I mentioned,
you would be able to
gauge how fast you
go depending on the regularity
on the function of the left.
So you have some methods
that can take adaptive steps.
And then the second
point is that in terms
of errors that you're
committing, once you solve
that equation, they are only
focused on the discretization
of the left part.
So you have less
sources of error.
And I'm going to sketch you
a derivation for which only
the high-level gist
is what I want you to.
So there are going to be
some intermediary results
that I'm just going to state.
And some equations we don't
need to know necessarily
how they are derived.
I'm just telling you
that they are there.
So let's start from
the forward SDE.
As Afshine had
mentioned it, you have
this f of x and t term, the
drift term, and the diffusion
term.
So it turns out
that for equations
that verify this equality, you
can apply the Fokker-Planck
equation, where you have
this pt of x that comes up.
That is the probability
of the flow.
And you have two terms
on the right that
could be interpreted
in physical terms
by the term on the left
that is a transport
term and the one on the right
that you see g squared on, which
is the diffusion term.
So the derivation
of such an equation
is non-trivial and
is out of scope here.
I'm just going to state that we
are going through that results.
And then by
rearranging the terms
and using an identity
on pt, we can
come to another equation
that is called the continuity
equation that I'm
just going to tell you
that it's going to
be something that we
see in more details at the
beginning of next lecture.
But what's interesting about
that continuity equation is
that on the right
side, there is a factor
that is to be interpreted
as a velocity.
And the velocity is dx over dt.
So once you identify
that factor,
you can come up with an
equation that this term that
has been identified as the
velocity needs to verify.
And you come up with an
equation that is indeed an ODE,
and we call it the PF-ODE.
PF stands for Probability Flows.
And let's look at that
equation for a bit.
So just like we mentioned
a short time ago,
f and g are modeling
assumptions that
are the ones that we
had as assumptions
once you derive this
diffusion concept.
And what about the score?
So the score is also
something that we can know.
Because once you have a model
that can approximate this score,
you just have to
put x as inputs,
and you can get the score.
So what I want to say is that
this whole term that popped up
is all composed of
components that we can know.
OK, great.
And now I'm going
to re-emphasize
each side of that PF-ODE.
So it's an ODE we
said because we
don't have a stochastic term,
and it's probability flow
because it's an ODE that comes
from verifying the continuity
equation, that is, an
equation that is focused
on the probability flow.
And one interesting
thing about that equation
is that once you have an
initial condition on PT,
you can fully
characterize what P is.
But this is something that
you cannot say about x.
Because as you can see here, if
you have v that is solution--
that is part of this
equation, then if you add--
if you do v plus v null, where
v null verifies divergence
of v null and pt equals
0, then v plus v null also
can be plugged in here.
So all of that to say
that the probability flow
between the reverse SDE
and here are preserved.
But the trajectories are not.
OK.
So I went through a lot so far.
Any questions?
Yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yeah, fair.
So the question is, what's
the interpretation here?
So we did all these equations to
conserve the probability flow,
and the trajectories are
going to be different.
And they are characterized
with this modified
term on the v side.
So instead of having these--
so you have this one
half that came in,
and that compensates for
the stochasticity part
that disappears.
So you're going to
still have trajectories
that verify in aggregate the
probability flow conditions,
but they are going
to be different.
And the interpretation is not
average or anything specific.
I would say it's just
that in aggregate, they
verify the probability flow
property at each time t and x.
[AUDIO OUT]
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the question is, will they
end up with the same properties
that you have the
distribution at the end?
And the answer is yes,
because PT is preserved.
OK.
Awesome.
And so I'm going to
draw a comparison
between solving that reverse
SDE equation and using PF-ODE.
So exactly as we mentioned
here, the term on the left,
like the drift term, is
compensated for that lack
of stochastic term.
And then the great
point that you made
is that we no longer have
something that is stochastic.
But once you have an
initial condition,
you deterministically
know where you're going.
So that's one big
difference that you
might remember from last
time resembles something
that you know.
And as a result, since the
only source of diversity
is now your initial draw, you
have less sampling diversity.
And interestingly, when
you look at experiments,
you have higher sample quality.
And that could be explained
intuitively by the fact
that you introduce
noise at each time step
enables you to explore
regions of the space
that you wouldn't have explored
with a deterministic path.
And you may self-correct
your trajectory, as opposed
to resolving an ODE
that is only conditioned
on your initial points
and all the errors
that you accumulate by
solving the ODE numerically.
So you have a nice
interpretation there.
And of course, now that
we have an ODE where
we can adapt step
sizes, you can now
resolve this faster,
which is a nice property.
And the fact that
I told you that I'm
drawing a very similar
parallel between PF-ODE
and the reverse SDE as the one
I drew last week between DDIM
and DDPM, we can see a lot
of shared commonalities
that I've put here
for reference.
And now let's look at how we can
solve this equation in practice
and if we can do even
better than regular solvers.
In order to do that, I'm
going to introduce a way
to assess complexity
that is widely used
in these papers called NFE.
So it's the number of
function evaluations.
And what we want to
do is for a sampler
to get good quality results
with a minimum amount of NFEs.
So it's a measure that makes
intuitive sense in the sense
that we want to minimize
the number of forward passes
that you perform on your model.
And I'm going to introduce
this notion of solving
an ODE by the very simple
method that some of you
might know already,
so Euler's method.
If you consider this ODE
dx equals v of x and t dt,
you can, based on
your initial point
and the derivative
at that point,
approximate the next point.
But the issue with that is that
there is quite a bit of errors.
Even though it's just
one NFE per step,
you end up with the results
that might be imprecise.
So people to account for
that fact are using a fancier
techniques, so Runge-Kutta
4 is one of them that--
so I represent it here on this
graph the intuition of it.
So you look at midpoints,
measure the derivative,
have some derivative measurement
on the endpoint as well.
And if you do some weighting
out of all of this,
you obtain an update step
that is of low error rate.
I think here it's O of delta
t to the power of 5, which
is nice.
So you might tell me,
OK, hey, Shervine, we
have solved everything.
We have a nice sampling method.
What could we do better?
So actually let's look
again at v of x and t.
So I told you it's f of x and
t minus this term on the right
that is divided by 2.
But if you look at
all the equations
that we use in the
diffusion world,
you see that f and x and t can
be rewritten as f of t times x.
So what does that tell you?
So that tells you that
this ODE is linear in x.
So it has a linear term.
And what can you say about
the term on the right?
Is it linear or--
so you would have x
as an input to where?
What is the term on the right?
The one in the rectangle.
It's the score.
So the score is what
we try to estimate
as part of our reverse
diffusion process.
And it's typically
something that you
would approximate
with a neural network.
And neural networks,
are they linear?
No, they're highly nonlinear.
After the first layer and
first activation function,
it's no longer linear.
So you have a
nonlinear term there.
And one thing we
could do is instead
of trying to discretize
this whole equation
without leveraging the fact
that part of it is linear,
we can use some
math properties that
says that with methods like
the variations of constants
that some of you
might have heard of,
you can derive an exact
solution to part of it
and focus the discretization
process on the other part.
And that's what DPM
solver is all about.
And I'm going to spare you
the details of the derivation.
It's quite long.
I have attached the paper
at the bottom in case
you're interested.
It's a bit involved.
You get an update formula that
has this exact term on the left
and then some
integral on the right.
And the integral on the right
focuses On the nonlinear term
that we saw.
And one highlight
that I'll mention here
is that we are not solving
this in the time space.
There has been a
change of variables,
and this is what the lambda
that you see in this equation
stands for.
And there is a
one-to-one mapping
between time steps and lambdas.
Because lambda is
strictly monotonic here.
So yeah, this is one
interesting thing to note.
And the question now is, how
do we discretize this equation?
Because we have this
integral now left.
And we cannot integrate
something that is approximated
by a neural network
over a continuous range.
So what we do is that
this is the part that
is going to be discretized.
And you have variants
of DPM solver
that discretize it at different
levels of granularity.
So the first one is DPM
solver 1 that the paper
shows gives an equation that
is equivalent to DDIM actually.
And DPM solver 2 uses
Taylor's expansion
at higher levels
up to any number k.
And the number-- so the NFE
for each is of I plus 1--
is of I, sorry.
And so to recap what we
did is that we started
from the forward SDE, rearranged
terms using properties
that we knew of.
Came up with a PF-ODE that
verified the same probability
flow.
And that enabled us to
generate new samples.
And then we leveraged
the format of the PF-ODE
to further optimize the
way we would resolve it
by focusing our NFEs on the
discretization parts that really
matters here.
And here you see that DPM
solver resolves the ODE
with a much better trade-off
between budget and quality.
And the difference
on the paper you
can see it at low
number of steps
they're quite huge
in terms of N metric.
And then just like
DDIM, you don't
need to retrain the
network when you
want to sample with this solver
because the objective function
is the same.
And in practice, with
only tens of NFEs,
you can get good results.
And that was it.
I hope you have a great weekend.